- We're gonna rap about you guys
and what you are wearing
and look like, I guess,
in a nice way.
(laughter)
(hip hop beat plays)
♪ Gonna go there. ♪
♪ Kick it off, like it's a lil' bowler. ♪
♪ Got a little heart on
the top, don't kill me. ♪
♪ Talking 'bout that
top hat, or a Trilby. ♪
♪ I don't even know about
the names, got to learn. ♪
♪ Got a milliner looking silly there, ♪
♪ with the fern. ♪
♪ And it's dry, and it's brown,
and it's no longer green, ♪
♪ kinda like fall on the scene, yeah. ♪
♪ Got a sunflower there on the mask, ♪
♪ looking like Van Gogh up to the task ♪
♪ When it comes to the
painting, you can reveal, ♪
♪ got to keep that nose covered, ♪
♪ But got teal around the outside. ♪
♪ That's blue, what we do though? ♪
♪ Call these dungarees and I do flow. ♪
♪ What do you call these
though? Coveralls? ♪
♪ I don't even know when
I'm over here with y'all... ♪
♪ What does your t-shirt say? ♪
♪ Maybe pull that to the side. We say ♪
♪ Looking like that with
the green and the stripe, ♪
♪ asking you to strip when I'm like ♪
♪ Beatles yes, that's my
goal. George Harrison, ♪
♪ Ringo Starr, rock and roll. ♪
♪ Inventing that shit, in the 60s. ♪
♪ Well technically, they
didn't, that is risky. ♪
♪ Going off to Berlin to play, ♪
♪ over in Hamburg, what can I say? ♪
♪ Loving that jacket.
I don't reject that. ♪
♪ Loving the fabric, I see polyester. ♪
♪ Keep it away from the flame. ♪
♪ Otherwise, oh, getting the blame. ♪
♪ When you get fire thing,
you end up dead. ♪
♪ Like all the Grateful
ones that I said. ♪
♪ Ooh, seeing all the
rainbow, going round there. ♪
♪ Got a lightning bolt
looking teddy bear ♪
♪ with the skeletons. ♪
♪ Seeing all of them why? ♪
♪ Got the color that's tie dyed. ♪
♪ And the mask with the
white little flowers. ♪
♪ Also more leaves up to your power. ♪
♪ Gathered from trees and you
put them in the brim, yeah. ♪
♪ or the second time of asking. ♪
♪ Nice big boots, that's
where we're starting, ♪
♪ from the toes up, that's Doc Martens. ♪
♪ No laces, just elastic. ♪
♪ Walking 'round and
you know I task it. ♪
♪ What's there on your hoodie? ♪
♪ Where is it come from? ♪
♪ Don't be a goodie,
coming to the university, ♪
♪ open it up. ♪
♪ Fine name that, yeah. ♪
♪ Close up. Again. ♪
♪ Hofstra, where the fuck? ♪
♪ Got to get a map to look it up. ♪
♪ I be like, whoa, you should stay man. ♪
♪ Wearing the glasses,
presumably Ray-Bans. ♪
♪ I like it, go long. ♪
♪ Wearing the khaki, the head is blonde. ♪
♪ Also, seen that one. ♪
♪ Repping that shit in the AJ1s, yeah. ♪
(crowd cheering, applause)
- [Narrator] If you would
like a Chris Turner hat
or face mask, they're on
sale now at goodsirla.com.
- Types of purses, fly fishing
while eating a lamb curry,
the shambles in York, and getting engaged.
Let's drop a beat, let's do this.
(Smooth hip hop beat)
♪ The first one, don't bore when I talk, ♪
♪ I've never visited, but
the shambles in York. ♪
♪ It's a shopping street. ♪
♪ You can meet a lot of
friends and locals. ♪
♪ I go there, shout, rap, and be vocal. ♪
♪ York, it's a great city. ♪
♪ Best of all, started by the Romans. ♪
♪ They be erecting a wall, put it up. ♪
♪ No invasion, when you shopping. ♪
♪ And if I'm walking
'round, then I'm watching. ♪
♪ Not hop scotching, like jumping over. ♪
♪ I see a little purse, I'm
a handbag loaver, lover. ♪
♪ I had to make it rhyme. ♪
♪ When push comes to shove,
you can put it in your thing. ♪
♪ That's a clutch from above? ♪
No chain there
Like Kate Spade, if you don't
like leather, you dismayed.
I get a purse that's a handbag.
Maybe like mine, technically
a man bag, time to find...
Whoa! Nose getting exposed
I don't rehearse
Moving on. I only know the two types
of purses, maybe diamante
with a gold clasp,
getting engaged. Are
you up to the task?
Yeah you were.
You were like filled with glee.
Whip a ring out
When you're down on one
knee, will you be my bride?
I don't know what to say.
Do it on the 29th of Feb,
the other way
Did you know once every four
years crazy, you can propose.
Even if you're the lady,
that's a true fact or an urban myth.
I love the ocean
but it's hard to resist
the call of the river.
I feel a little shiver when I get my rod
out and I give her a big
cast...away like I'm Tom Hanks.
Standing there in the
middle, not the river bank.
I got the fly
on the end, I tie it on my
bench, but I'm feeling hungry.
I need to get hench.
So I called my friend Iqbal
in a hurry and say, yo,
bro, I need a lamb curry
it comes to me, floats my boat.
I prefer the lamb
less chewy than goat,
but less flavor as well.
That's a rap
for you while I'm eating
all the Curry made of ewe.
Female sheep, female sheep.
I thought I'd end it
with a really good joke.
And they were like, we don't
know what that pun is Chris
(laughter)
But you would like a rap about?
- Kansas city chiefs.
Cool.
- Pizza rolls toasted, not microwaved.
- Great, and?
- Peanut butter and jelly sandwiches.
great. Let's let's do this.
(hip hop beat)
Freestyle off the dome today.
I keep it classic in my sandwich.
Got the PB and J, always
smooth, never chunky.
I ain't no monkey.
I've got the flavor but the aroma's funky.
Got the peanut butter breath
feeling kind of smelly
mixed it with the grape, got
the Smucker's for the jelly.
I can take any type
of wholemeal slice when
it comes to lunchtime,
a snack that I like.
And here we go: a win
that defies belief - victory
in the super bowl for those
chiefs coming from Kansas city.
Yeah. You saw he, Trump
He tweeted it.
Not in Missouri.
Thought it was Kansas red on
his face, egg on his face.
Why? Because he got the wrong state.
They were winning it
Yeah. Being real hot.
But I must say it's weird
that they got the mascot, like a red face
Indian, maybe Cherokee
I don't know.
Native American geography.
Technically what's the tribe in the area.
Here's the thing in the
kitchen scared of ya.
Nah, I keep it placid.
When I go to lovin'
get a pizza roll and
I shove it in the oven
even though the microwave
or toaster oven will be better
And let me say it keeps it
moist the pastry is wetter
One problem
with the microwave, you
can burn cause it stays
with the heat for days,
like I'm dropping down fire
now but I get the goal.
Get the mozzarella
in the pizza roll, stick
it in my hole drop it
down my esophagus. Really hot.
Like the molten lava at
the center of the earth.
Still a great midnight snack.
I prefer it to the PB and J. Thwack.
Thanks for watching.
Please do like
and subscribe and check out
one of my freestyle videos.